remember that membership is our primary
funding source
i invite you to grab a membership at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code
2020 now all one word all lowercase 2020
now to save 66
if you could imagine that is a discount
that is
certainly immoral and sometimes illegal
depending where you live it's too big of
a discount grab a membership at
jointpakman.com
i was browsing the david pakman show
subreddit this morning at
davidpakman.com
slash reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
um and i saw a post called
what the hell is wrong with you
americans
which says i mean seriously last night's
debates wouldn't even be normal
in turkmenistan that's an insult to the
turkmenis
what the hell happened to you people you
used to be the amazing people now you
are looking at two geriatric rapists
snarling half-finished sentences
and blatant lies to each other what the
hell happened i i reject the
characterization of two geriatric
rapists it seems like maybe you've
fallen
for some uh unconfirmed conspiracy
theories there or or
or what whatever the case may be but uh
dozens of emails like that coming in
from all over the world
what is wrong with you people even if
trump loses as i've been saying
how are 60 million of you voting for
this guy
and this is a reality we have to contend
with the world
at one point maybe they were laughing
they're
shocked the rest of the world is
disgusted the rest of the world
pities us the rest of the world is
concerned because we have more than 60
million people here
who not only voted for trump but they're
going to do it again
another user on the subreddit nerdlinger
says is anybody else not even surprised
that people are defending
trump's performance yesterday blaming
chris wallace accusing biden of having
an earpiece playing the both sides game
as if both candidates were completely
unhinged last night
acting offended over biden calling trump
a clown
proud boys aren't white nationalists i
figured this would happen if trump gave
the most indefensible appearance
possible and he did
and i'm not at all surprised really i
feel so desensitized to this stuff now
david really needs to do a good long
episode on
long-term implications of trumpism
um yeah i i mean we knew
listen every debate every year every
election cycle
each side claims they won trump claims
he won biden claims he won
um in in reality uh what really matters
is how the the relatively few and far
between
undecided voters um see it
because trump's base is already voting
for trump the anti-trump people are
already
voting for joe biden um so it's not
really surprising
that the trump base is defending trump's
performance
but you were right about the unfortunate
reality as i said
just because of the last reddit post
even if trump loses what happens with
trumpism
and i think that there is a real risk
that if donald trump gets re-elected
it's not just four more years of trump
it bolsters the possibility
of one of the trump children running in
2024
and things get even uglier if you can
imagine that
last notable post from the subreddit
from user
genius of slaughter who says trump
saying he would run the country like his
business is the only true thing he's
ever said
look at trump's tax returns man so
inspirational
yet can can we put to bed this idea
that we need a business person president
this is something that we heard when
mitt romney was running
in 2012 and at the time the question was
what example do we have of a businessman
turned president that did really well
and there there were no examples
we now have a supposed businessman
turned president and it's been an
unmitigated and total disaster
uh so so we we need to stop with that
and in fact
i would love to see presidents come from
other backgrounds altogether what about
a scientist
president what about a president with a
background in education
uh or philosophy as an example or or
maybe even economics i know you know
some some maybe wouldn't like that but
we we actually have a problem where the
scope of where presidents come from is
too narrow
uh and and i think we would be uh far
better served
to expand it in other directions than
businessman president
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit